my youngest brother justin died of a
heroin overdose
[Music]
on wednesday
december 5th of 2018
driving to rockford illinois with our
dad
to identify justin at the hospital the
following day was a painful experience
so many miles so much painful silence
seeing my baby brother in the er
intubated and gone was one of if not the
most traumatic experiences of my life
he was so handsome his hair is so
freaking amazing he used to rub it in my
face all the time his beautiful thick
wavy hair as i complained about mine
thinning with age
all i could do standing next to his
lifeless body was run my hands through
his hair and kiss his cold forehead
i was genuinely heartbroken and at that
moment all i could do was drop to the
floor and stop i just sobbed
uncontrollably
i literally couldn't believe i was
looking at my baby brother dead
you don't ever wipe a memory like that
out of your mind and for the next 12
months it would literally haunt me every
day
at the end of 2019 i was drinking
alcohol in an abusive way numbing the
pain from drowning in grief over losing
justin and our mom just two years prior
in fact i suffered many losses in the
years leading up to justin's death
two miscarriages a marriage and a uterus
to be exact
i knew the way i was handling what life
was throwing at me wasn't sustainable
but more importantly i didn't want it to
be
and i knew only big changes would create
significant results so i created this
challenge in my mind that i would run
one 5k every month for a year until i
could do that without stopping to walk
i also committed to something bigger
my annual dry january would be a dry
2020 instead yes i was giving up alcohol
for an entire year
i was committed to changing my life
story and set out to transform myself
from the inside out i was determined and
felt unstoppable
over the past two years i have found a
lot of purpose in my pain and it has
changed my life
listening to your podcast and the wide
variety of characters and life stories
you've unveiled has truly helped me get
here
from november 2019 to the end of 2020
through a global pandemic no less i
managed to run 19 races most of those
were live if you can believe that and
the last three were back to back half
marathon the last of which i ran
straight through without stopping to
walk even one
living a great story while i'm here on
earth is my goal every day i want to be
the person who looks in the mirror every
day and feels pride i am that person
today and i'll do my best to be that
person tomorrow too i hope you do too
[Music]
so
there you have it that was the beginning
of the story of the rest of my life
the follow-up is that i did introduce
alcohol back into my life this year
after my usual dry january
but this time it was different
unlike past years where i just go back
to drinking and i don't think about it
this time i've done it with a keen
awareness because after being sober all
of 2020 i had something tangible to
compare my life to and what i've
concluded beyond a shadow of a doubt is
that my life is just exponentially
better without alcohol playing any kind
of role
i am definitely nada have a glass of
wine with dinner and don't drink for two
weeks kinda gal i'm just not so for me
labeling myself has become irrelevant
what is relevant is that drinking is
like hitting the mute button on my life
and being sober is like turning the
volume up to ten and i am definitely a
turn up the volume type of person
so after a year-long soul-searching
mission i've committed once again to
sobriety but this time my goal is a
lifestyle choice not just a year-long
challenge
december 5th will no longer just be the
day justin died
december 5th will also be the day i
chose to live
thank you
thank you for your courage
for taking the leap for calling in and
and being vulnerable and for walking
this journey alongside me i sincerely
hope you enjoyed this episode as much as
i did i would also appreciate it if you
would consider sharing this special
episode with your friends or on social
media thanks for listening see you back
here soon peace